intended for Seth Jarvis and a two-on
one back the other way trended shoots
kicked out by R and he made the second
stop on Jeremy loan and Novak's pass
broken up by T terrain glov down by
Tommy Novak hangs on to him the shot
to save R rebound back head and did that
go over the line looked like it might have
Uso Parson is the 22-year-old from Finland with
his six goal you see right there opportunity to
get the puck out of the Zone they try to clear it
out Nashville keeps it in it chipped out of there
by Marty NES for Jack Drury who had the first goal
for the canes last night in the win against the
wings D'Angelo still out there one touch and two
scores with n parked in front and this game is
tied
Mike as you say as D'Angelo stays out there
on this power play and and you can see just
finds that little soft area and n's going
to get that tip on this one but Drury just
all of it I see from your team second night
of a back to back he said you just got to
be right in your face with the way you're
playing got to force yourself in the game
take a hit or give a hit I always used to
say but get in the game right back to the
power play they scor D'Angelo from the point
might have been tipped by Bunting and Carolina
leads right off the draw Carolina's going to take
advantage and it's a one battle along the wall by
bunting this is going to go back to D'angelo and
all he's going to try to do is get this on net I
don't think bunting ends up getting a piece of
this but definitely Lincoln I think is prepared
for bunting to tip and he doesn't ends up going
between his legs but it's all one battle look at
all the national predators are on one side of
the ice d'angel has room to walk to the middle
and now Nyquist in the corner sweeps it along
for Roman Yosi right point on the back pedal
chipped it back deep for Nyquist spills out
for O'Reilly O'Reilly Shadow there finds Yosi
Yosi creates space Yosi takes it behind and
scores Roman Yosi on a Rapp around ties it at
two as he carries this through the whole Zone and
it's gonna start look at how he's activating he
forces that the Dem man stall to get pushed back
create some space for himself and in doing so he
comes around and wraps that one in but it's so
hard to defend a guy like Yosi CU you don't know
if he's going to jump St think he's going to
jump deep he gets some time in space wraps it
around Ron gets caught up in front of the net at
347 from O'Reilly and Nyquist up to 24 points on
the Season 22 first five minutes of the second
Martin go spinning inside the line pulls up
cross ice buting back door and shaffield
scores Carolina's back in front tick tac
toe here Carolina you got to be happy with
the response on this one it's martinook on
the entry he pulls up and chatfield's
going to go to the net strong just to
the back door you can see he comes all the
way from the other end using his speed he
recognizes right here he drives through pass
over to him back door we talked about the 11
and seven for Carolina and Rod bore told us
pregame part of that's because Chatfield has
been quote too good to take out and he
contributes again with his first point
in the last six games and the can's lead n
for AO back to AO scores and the blink of an
eye this time since their skill guys getting it
done and this one is pretty SEC going be Jarvis
trying to keep that puck in but it's a turnover
that in little give go here AO finishes it puts
it into the back of the net but it all starts with
Burns he doesn't ba out he stays in he chips it
in N is having a great season for the Hurricanes
Lozan in the corner sizin off the post sizin on
the retrieval off the turnover ao's pass for char
is broken up by MCD carried ahead by Tommy Novak
pulls up at the line mcdna joins shoots off the
iron for siss back to the line Yosi for forsberg
blocked by slaven bangs with forsberg and worked
out to the half wall for Nyquist chops it back
to Roman Yosi at the line Yosi dancing down the
wall forbord and they score on the rebound it's
O Ry and on the power play the PRS pull within one
it's definitely been a special teams game there's
no question about this Nashville's going to get
this one on the power play it's a great keep in
here from Yosi get an opportunity to clear you
don't that on usually end up in the backer head
it's a simple shot to the front and O'Reilly's all
by himself he lets this one go through rant kicks
it up eight of them have come on the power play
he's one off the NHL lead of Brock besser with
nine that's impressive he's such a good player
and last SS one wide he does off the ice two in
the room with his leadership and and you know how
guys in the NHL talk everybody I talk to they have
nothing but great things to say off the turnover
the cage scored Marty NES restores a TW goal lead
even if they on the ice setting up in the back
of the net it's going to be a good opportunity
but he misses the shot wide Nashville does it's
going to come back to the other end by the for
Carri actually just going to throw thow this one
out in front of the net it's NIS is going to be
rewarded terrifying and you can see him with
this pressure here 25 seconds after I think we
were talking about Ryan O'Reilly if memory serves
but uh another goal Marty NES indeed 25 seconds
later Smith settles it down he feeds it across
here's Barry he scores this is Mayhem a one goal
game again back and forth we go Mike and Carolina
has possession in the offensive zone Puck's going
to get chipped out and Barry's going to grab
this one and beats R short side thomasino here
all he's doing is trying to get this Puck out dman
gets caught though oh J gave it away forsberg out
and Thro BR makes the save on Evangelista and
then blocked in front by pesi off for thomasino
thomasino another try yosi's on it on the
retrieval Yosi starts in behind thomasino oh the
save by rat cooler heads prevail now n's speeds in
turns it back in the direction of Sebastian AO and
the Predators race ahead three on two Parson it
for Evangelista the shot score loan has tied it at
five great play from Nashville on this one it's
just a breakout n uh Carolina gets caught see
PES on the wrong side of the ice three on two
back the other way lazan joins as a dman and
you can see he beats up Carolina's forwards
up the ice they get caught just patience he
finds that soft area as Yosi sck handles and
elicit booze pass toward O'Reilly and forsberg
fortunately for Nashville gloved down by Philip
forsberg forsberg darts to the slot shoots scor
it's over the PRS win it and again it's Philip
forsberg in overtime for the second time in his
many games 18 seconds into overtime took a
little bit longer here tonight yeah looked
like they're going to lose possession there
but forsburg drives Burns back gets his Puck
on his forehand and catches r as he tries
to come across rant's moving surprises him
a little bit with that shot to get it past
him but he picks it up in the neutral zone
then it's all forsberg after that drives a
deep back cuts to the middle shoots in stride